ten de à la une ce soir la pologne en
état de crise depuis ce matin les
chantiers navals de gdansk se sont
joints à la grève le slogan est simple
pas de liberté sans solidarité alors au
delà des images qui nous arrivent toutes
les heures de pologne
nous vous expliquerons pourquoi depuis
1980 le pays est vraiment tiraillé entre
le compromis et la révolte
en attendant voici comme chaque soir les
autres grands titres du journal
puma social s'alourdit la régie renault
vient de refuser la réintégration de 24
militants cgt
henri krasucki réagi durement devant les
caméra l'antenne 2 pour lui la
responsabilité du gouvernement est
engagé
l'irlande du nord 48 heures après le
nouvel attentat de l'ira
madame thatcher avec l'arrêt tout à
l'heure qu'aucune option n'était exclue
pour lutter contre le terrorisme au
népal et en main de bilan d'une
catastrophe le séisme d'hier matin
auraient fait plus de 800 morts et dix
mille blessés
il y aurait 50 milles sans abri la
solidarité internationale s'organise
sport le président de la fédération
française de football répondra en direct
à nos questions monsieur fournet-fayard
nous dira comment il compte réagir aux
propos d'eric cantona je vous rappelle
que la vedette de l'om s'en est pris
violemment au sélectionneur national en
le traitant notamment d'incapables
l'épreuve de force en pologne après les
mines et or de haute silésie les
chantiers navals de gangs sont en grève
donc depuis ce matin bref symbole dans
une ville qui demeure vous le savez le
bastion de l'opposition la plus radicale
au pouvoir du général géruzez le ski ce
soir alors que les unités anti-émeutes
polonaises ont pris position autour des
chantiers navals
on a vraiment l'impression une fois de
plus que le pouvoir et les dirigeants de
l'opposition se trouve débordé par la
base au-delà des grèves des ultimatums
et des intimidations policières
le comité de grève annonce qu'il
poursuivra son action jusqu'à la
victoire finale
martine laroche joubert larmes de la
grève ou contre l'inertie du pouvoir
avec une fois de plus la même question
jusqu'où tiendront-ils mais cette
fois-ci l'art défi paraît solide mineurs
dockers ouvriers ils seraient plus de
70000 en arrêt de travail aujourd'hui
avec une unique revendication le
pluralisme syndical c'est à dire la
reconnaissance officielle de solidarité
les augmentations salariales elles
passent au second plan
d'où l'immobilisme du pouvoir qui
jusqu'à présent avaient désamorcé les
grèves par des hausses de salaires un
pouvoir qui hésite sur la tactique à
suivre
l'armée à quitter les abords de
plusieurs chantiers restent les homos
les forces anti-émeutes dont la présence
tout au moins sur les images que nous
recevons paraît plutôt discrète l'église
tente de jouer un rôle d'intermédiaire
difficile car c'est le silence des
autorités qui accroît la tension et
provoque même l'hypothèse d'un nouvel
état de siège
gilles diop
aujourd'hui la proclamation de l'état de
siège à nouveau en pologne signifierait
la faillite totale du régime du général
jarre vous esquive les faits ne seraient
plus du tout le même pour 1981
ce serait la fin du règne de l'équipe au
pouvoir
le fait le plus important aujourd'hui
c'est la participation des mineurs aux
mouvements de grève
ils y participent très rarement mais
sont connus pourtant qu'on leur très
grande détermination les grèves en ce
moment sont réduits et les ouvriers
cette fois ci ne céderont pas facilement
nous venons d'apprendre que les polonais
attendent en ce moment même une
déclaration du ministre de l'intérieur
qui en 1981 avait mis en oeuvre l'état
de guerre le moment est peut-être au
basculement d'un côté comme de l'autre
la nouvelle épreuve de force entre le
gouvernement polonais et les
responsables de solidarnosc qui survient
huit ans presque jour pour jour après
les grandes grèves de 1980 à gdansk des
greffes qui avait conduit à la création
du syndicat solidarnosc qui depuis cette
date
la pologne est tiraillé entre le
compromis et la révolte je le disais
tout à l'heure les événements
enregistrés récemment nous aide à mieux
comprendre l'escaladé de la tension et
surtout l'impasse dans laquelle se
trouve actuellement le régime polonais
explications de jacques merlino
parce vie en novembre dernier nous
sommes à deux jours du référendum décidé
par le général jaruszalski les murs se
couvrent d' affiches appelant la
population à dire oui aux réformes
timides proposée par le pouvoir
le pays est calme désabusé fatigué par
des années de crise et l'absence de
perspectives le référendum se heurte un
désintérêt général
c'est ça ne m'intéresse pas je ne vois
pas je crois que ça va t'apporter
grand-chose façon puisque le
gouvernement a déjà prévu le pourcentage
de personnes qui vont y aller aussi bien
que les résultats
je crois que ça va plus la peine de
donner notre notre moi parce que ça josé
ce qui fait tout pour convaincre
s'efforce de changer d'image apparaît à
la télévision entouré de jeunes mais
rien n'y fait surprise pour la première
fois dans un pays communiste
le pouvoir est désavoué par les
électeurs les noms et les
abstentionnistes l'emportent
le référendum est rejetée l'hiver passe
tout le monde a perdu jersey ce qui n'a
pu faire passer sa réforme
solidarnosc surpris par l'échec du
référendum est à court de
contre-propositions devant les magasins
toujours les files d'attentes et
phénomène nouveau
l'apparition d'une extrême pauvreté les
polonais sont de plus en plus nombreux à
se transformer en prochain et l'on voit
même en plein varsovie une disciple de
soeur thérésa ouvrir en hospice pour
nécessiteux travail
avant je travaillais chez un type dans
le privé mais il a fait payer alors je
n'ai plus rien maintenant il n'y a
qu'ici on s'occupe de moi
l'opposition tourne à vide sans mot
d'ordre sans stratégie et la population
désemparée ne trouve pour s'exprimer
d'autres lieux que l'église
et bien souvent le dimanche soir dans la
capitale polonaise
la messe pour la patrie se terminant
manifestations spontanées vite réprimées
par la police
huawei voix
ouais
les jeunes de leur côté ne croit plus en
rien l on peut rencontrer en plein coeur
de varsovie des filles et des garçons
qui se saoule à la bière en se moquant
de tout lui par le français il a vécu
dix ans avec son cher en afrique
je te laisse pas le jeu c'est pas je te
laisse pas le socialisme par exemple je
n'aime pas parce que je trouve que enfin
je suis seul je suis seul et je tolère
pas ce dont j'ai envie de partir à
l'ouest 1er février et 1er mars 1er
avril en 3 rafale de hausses décidées
par le gouvernement
les prix sont multipliés par 2 3 ou 4
l'économie devient folle le marché noir
devient la règle et si c'est mal son nom
comme d'état ici ce marché noir s'est
passé noël c'est marché noir officiel
c'est pas mal
13 juillet 1988 la pologne accueille
gorbatchev la population plein d'espoir
retient son souffle
mais la déception est terrible le
pouvoir ne la charia la pérestroïka ne
passera pas la frontière les prémices de
la crise sont en place voilà on attend
je vous le rappelle une déclaration
imminente à la télévision polonaise du
ministre de l'intérieur polonais nous y
reviendrons vraisemblablement dans le
courant de cette édition
la quête de la liberté au quotidien
c'est aussi ce soir une image qui nous
parvient de berlin
quatre hommes une femme vous allez les
voir viennent de passer à l'ouest leur
fuite est à la fois synonyme de des
presses et de beaucoup de détermination
pour la première fois une caméra a pu
saisir la scène regardez trois hommes et
une femme ont réussi à fuir l'allemagne
de l'est
en franchissant à la nage lâche près la
rivière qui passe à berlin
c'est la rive à l'ouest qui constitue la
ligne de démarcation entre les deux
secteurs de la ville
la rivière elle même et sur le
territoire de berlin est et les réfugiés
ont d'ailleurs échappé de peu à une
vedette est-allemand qui patrouillait
cet endroit où les deux villes sont
distantes de 80 m
conséquence de la nouvelle politique en
urss erich honecker le numéro un est
allemand a fait retirer de la frontière
les systèmes de tirs automatiques
les gardes frontière ont même reçu
l'ordre pour certaines périodes de ne
pas tirer sur les fugitifs les on est
encore loin d'envisager la destruction
du mur de berlin construit il ya 27 ans
les quatre fugitifs de dimanche sont
sortis indemnes de leur traversée à
l'exception d'un jeune femme blessée à
la cheville
en france la ministre sur la sellette on
a appris cet après midi que la direction
de la régie renault refuse et la
réintégration de 24 militants cgt parmi
eux figurent les dix militants licencié
à lusine de boulogne billancourt dans la
région parisienne la direction motive
son refus par le fait que les dix
salariés ont été licenciés pour raison
économique fin de citation dès cet
après-midi vive réaction de la cgt la
centrale d'henri krasucki affirme que la
responsabilité du gouvernement est
directement engagée
nous plaçons le gouvernement devant ses
responsabilités comme je les dis il ya
un instant tenté d'intimider le monde du
travail en ce moment en appliquant porte
comme il se doit la liste y est en
euh réparant pas les préjudices causés
aux droits syndicaux et bien c'est
aboutir à un rogue plus intense encore
des luttes sociales tous azimuts chars
leclerc on a l'impression que le ton
monte on vient d'entendre traces du
kippour là pour la cgt il ya aussi est
faux il ya également le cnpf qui
s'attendent à une rentrée agitée est-ce
que l'automne sera chaud pour employer
une terminologie syndical on vous l'avez
dit vous savez c'est un peu une
tradition chaque année les météorologues
sociaux annonce un automne chaud et des
orages sociaux qui en fait n'éclate pas
durant l'été la cgt s'est efforcé de
maintenir la pression autour des mineurs
de gardanne où des dix licenciés de
billancourt
dans un autre registre andré bergeron
est d'accord avec le patronat pour
pronostiquer une rentrée plus difficile
plus turbulente qu'à l'ordinaire
d'ailleurs après quelques années de
calme plat liées à la crise le nombre
des conflits a sensiblement augmenté au
premier semestre dans les prochaines
semaines la contestation pourrait surfer
sur quelques déferlante l'emploi qui se
détériore le refus de la mystique pour
des syndicalistes licenciés véritable
cheval de bataille pour la cgper vient
de voir
et puis surtout le pouvoir d'achat pour
force ouvrière la revalorisation des
salaires après plusieurs années de
stagnation est un problème majeur au
moment où les entreprises annonce de
bons résultats paul marchelli le
président de l'encadrement cgc réclament
des négociations par branches
professionnelles
et voilà que même le ministre pierre
bérégovoy et admet qu'il existe un
problème qu'il faut en discuter
le gouvernement va montrer l'exemple en
rouvrant des négociations avec les
fonctionnaires et en lâchant au besoin
un petit quelque chose pour compenser
l'inflation plus forte que prévu nombre
d'entreprises ont aussi pris les devants
en accordant discrètement quelques coups
de pouce et en freinant
l'individualisation des salaires mais la
marge de manoeuvre est étroite
un dérapage des salaires remettrait en
cause la lutte contre l'inflation
plus que jamais priorités du ministre de
l'économie qui en appelle donc à la
responsabilité des partenaires sociaux
alors l'actualité sociale c'est aussi la
traditionnelle interview d'edmond maire
dans les colonnes du monde aujourd'hui
chaque année le numéro un de la cfdt
fait un petit exercice de style
il choisit un thème cette année c'était
l'europe absolument l'adresse à la
formation cette année c'est donc
l'europe le devoir de vacances d'edmond
maire c'est l'europe et son absence de
contenu social qui risque de la rendre
impopulaire auprès des salariés le
secrétaire général de la cfdt fustige le
cnpf qui refuse toute harmonisation
sociale européenne alors qu'il faudrait
au contraire selon lui multiplié les
conventions collectives européenne et
rapprocher les différentes politiques de
l'emploi
des préoccupations qui faut noter sont
très proches de celles qui expriment et
andré bergeron dans le même journal le
monde il ya quelques jours vendredi
exactement merci gérard dernier bilan
d'une catastrophe au népal et en inde le
séisme qui a touché cette partie du
monde hier matin aurait fait entre 650
et 1000 morts
les équipes médicales se relaient
notamment au népal où se trouve
l'épicentre de la catastrophe
les blessés se comptent par dizaines de
milliers pascal deschamps l'inde et le
népal n'en finissent pas de pleurer
leurs morts
quelle somme ce soir ne se risque encore
à dresser le bilan des deux violentes
secousses d'hier matin la terre n'aura
tremblé que 40 secondes 40 petites
secondes et déjà on parle de 1000 morts
et le nombre des victimes s'alourdit
d'heure en heure tandis que l'armée la
police et des centaines de volontaires
fouillent les décombres dans l'espoir de
plus en plus mince de retrouver des
survivants
cet après midi rajiv gandhi le premier
ministre indien s'est rendu dans l'état
de bihar la région sinistrée à l'est du
pays
il a promis une aide de 400 dollars aux
familles des victimes
mais les besoins sont considérables il y
à ce soir des dizaines de milliers de
blessés et de sans abri les hôpitaux
sont débordés les médecins ce nom de
tous de sang et de médicaments
désormais les sinistrés des deux côtés
de la frontière attendent l'aide du
monde entier oui on vient d'apprendre
qu'un médecin français vient d'être
dépêchés sur place afin d'évaluer les
modalités de l'aide apportée par notre
pays si vous désirez vous aussi envoyer
des dons voici deux numéros de comptes
chèque postaux celui du secours
catholique et celui d'action d'urgence
internationale pour le secours
catholique compte chèque postal 737 g
paris en mentionnant inde 737 g paris en
mentionnant inde et pour actions
d'urgence international compte chèque
postal 15 820 17 p paris
j'espère que vous avez eu le temps de
noter les autres télégramme d'actualité
avec un doublé ce qui ensuite ne nous
arrêterons quelques minutes en irlande
du nord je vous rappelle que ce week-end
malheureusement huit soldats
britanniques ont trouvé la mort dans un
attentat revendiqué par l'ira situation
dramatique au burundi 5000 morts 25
mouvements les chiffres divergent
complètement
quant au nombre des tués lors des
affrontements qui opposent deux ethnies
les tutsis et les hutus une guerre d'un
autre âge les belligérants armés de
lances de machettes de gourdins
s'entretuent au nom de gay rancune qui
date de l'indépendance en 1962
khartoum parce que submergées par les
eaux la nuit dernière le nil a atteint
son niveau le plus élevé depuis 1946 un
million et demi de soudanais sont
victimes des inondations provoquées par
les pluies torrentielles qui s'abattent
sur le pays depuis trois semaines
l'aide internationale continue de
parvenir au soudan deux cent seize
avions au total seraient arrivés à
khartoum
hier soir dans les rues de la capitale
tchèque la manifestation marquant le 20e
anniversaire du printemps de prague a
plu a pu attirer les sympathisants et
rassemblé des milliers de manifestants
soixante dix sept personnes ont été
interpellées par la police
c'est la télévision tchèque aux
slovaques qui nous a fait parvenir ces
images en irlande du nord 48 heures
après l'attentât qui a coûté la vie à
huit militaires anglais londres semble
impuissant face à l'ira l'armée
républicaine irlandaise
de plus en plus des voix s'élèvent pour
réclamer le retour de la procédure
d'internement une procédure qui
permettrait aux forces de l'ordre
d'arrêter certains suspects pour
l'instant madame thatcher n'a pas pris
position mais elle a déclaré tout à
l'heure on vient de l'apprendre par une
dépêche qu'aucune option n'était exclue
pour lutter contre le terrorisme
hier soir dans le journal de 20h nous
vous avons présenté l'image d'une armée
britannique véritablement coincé entre
les communautés catholique et
protestante
ce soir gros plan sur une communauté
protestante qui représentent deux tiers
de la population
reportage en marque il use et philippe
rayter pour les images
bien sûr que c'est important de se
souvenir du roi william quand on est
protestant quand les protestants de
londonderry mettent leur chapeau melon
pour saluer la mémoire du bon roy
williams il ne s'agit pas pour eux de
folklore et chaque année ils défilent
pour glorifier la résistance héroïque
des 13 jeunes apprentis qui empêchèrent
leur citadelle de tomber aux mains du
méchant oad écosse un catholique
c'était en 1690 et si aujourd'hui cette
image reste gravé dans la mémoire de
chaque protestant de londonderry à
belfast sait qu en irlande du nord
on confond volontiers histoire et
actualité aujourd'hui comme hier la
communauté protestante de l'add-on déry
a le dos au mur
nous défilons surtout pour montrer à
tous que nous défendrons toujours notre
foi notre culture notre héritage
protestants et cela quoi qu'il arrive
quoi qu'il arrive l'allusion est
transparente du moins pour un protestant
deux fois plus nombreux que les
catholiques en irlande du nord
les protestants sont pourtant
minoritaire à londonderry
exactement comme il pourrait le devenir
demain dans une irlande réunifiée donc à
majorité catholique l'irlande de sud
aimerait bien nous avaler dit ce jeune
fonctionnaire il faut lui montrer que
nous restons fidèles à nos traditions
protestante
son de cloche identique chez grand père
ce technicien dans un laboratoire lui
craint par dessus tout l'église de rome
l'église de l'antéchrist dit il elle
dirige le monde ici nous n'accepterons
jamais de souci
d'ailleurs la jac
mais en dépit de la profondeur du
sentiment religieux en irlande du nord
le noeud du problème est politique
le refus par la majorité protestante
modéré compris de tout statut d'égalité
avec les catholiques
explications les protestants détiennent
la plupart des pouvoirs en matière
d'économie de police et de justice
héritier des colons britanniques
ils tiennent à le rester et ils prieront
encore et encore pour la reine et pour
la couronne 1690 1988 comme chaque année
depuis près de trois siècles les
protestants de londonderry auront donc
répété non seulement aux catholiques
mais aussi au gouvernement de londres
il ne négocierons jamais leur identité
voilà demain soir nous essaierons de
vous présenter un nouveau volet de
l'enquète de jean-marc il use et philipp
etter en irlande du nord
sport et plus particulièrement football
ce soir encore c'est le coup de tête
d'eric cantona qui alimente la chronique
le terme n'est pas trop fort je vous
rappelle que samedi soir au terme du
match de championnat strasbourg
marseille la vedette de l'om s'en était
prise ouvertement au sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france henri michel en
dénonçant je cite son incompétence
notoire était même allé un peu plus loin
certes ce n'est pas le premier écart de
langage du footballeur mais cette fois
ci monsieur cantona était tout de même
allé un peu loin alors conscient de ses
écarts de langage la star a mis quelques
bémols aujourd'hui mais les propos
d'hier sont encore gravés dans les
mémoires
écoutez on sait que henri michel va pas
rester longtemps à la tête de l'équipe
de france
moi je souhaite un jeu juste je le
souhaite surtout pour les joueurs que je
souhaite que les joueurs et de crin
résultat mais je souhaite qu'un jour sa
personne
karimi chien est l'une des plus
incompétents section nord du fujian
je lisais un truc de micro puisque c'est
une guerre que j'adore qui disait que
celui qui s'occupait des oscars à
hollywood a été un sac à merde
lascars émission à ne pas nous y voilà
votre réaction intéressante celle
d'henri michel henri michel concernés
dont les oreilles ont dû siffler ce
week-end l'entraîneur national prend la
faire avec beaucoup de philosophie
olivier rey oui henri henri michel a
essayé de calmer le jeu il est vrai que
c'est une année décisive pour le
football français puisque dans cinq
semaines le 28 septembre à paris
l'équipe de france rencontrera la
norvège un match qui compte pour les
qualifications à la prochaine coupe du
monde qui se déroulera en 90 en italie
alors écoutez henri michel qui essayent
d'apaiser un peu la situation
eric a appris une attitude aujourd'hui
il m'avait dit qu'il était capable c'est
vrai fallait faire attention internats
scolaires qu'il était capable aussi de
revenir
peu de temps après sur ce qu'il avait
dit il ya mon attitude j'essaye de
préserver j'essaye de comprendre de
faire comprendre
et puis aussi maintenant le pouvoir
fédéral qui lui a moyen d'intervention
et ça peut déboucher sur sur les
sanctions parce que il ya eu des choses
très graves de provence et vous avez des
informations sur ces éventuelles
sanctions déjà mais la déception
non ça ça appartient
au président sur une infiltration
président de la ligue et il faut il faut
être calme sereine et et voir ce que
nous pouvons faire le mieux possible
monsieur fournet-fayard bonsoir je
rappelle aux téléspectateurs que vous
êtes le président de la fédération
française de football est-ce que vous
avez eue cantona au téléphone nous notre
du tout non alors les sanctions dont
parlait henri michel
il en sera question demain je crois non
oui je pense qu'on a suffisamment à
travers médias interposés dialoguer sur
les déclarations d'eric cantona il est
temps maintenant qu'on entende le fautif
et puis qu on mesure en fonction de ce
qui nous confirmera qu'on mesure un
petit peu ce que l'avenir peut-être le
seul fonds des fire on attendait son
interview là on ne l'a pas eue il a
temporisé un petit peu ces propos est-ce
que ça va vous a cité un peu plus de
clémence demain je pense que c'est un
bon point pourrait devoir tempérer ses
propos mais vous savez il ya quand même
des choses
pratiquement irrémédiable qui ont été
commises et dans ses déclarations et a
prévu une chose qui a subsisté
c'est finalement son maintien le
maintien de sa position de dire qu'il ne
reviendrai pas en sélection si longtemps
quand les michel en serait le
sélectionneur ceci étant je profite de
l'occasion pour rappeler que ce n'est
pas aux joueurs de décider de sa
sélection ou du refus de la sélection
nous avons des dispositions qui nous
permette de combat henri michel de
convoquer tous joueurs licenciés à la
fédération française de football et
henri michel décide qui il veut utiliser
ou pas n'avez vous pas l'impression
président que depuis quelques temps il y
a beaucoup d'affaires dans le football
il ya eu la sphère fernandez aujourd'hui
cantona plusieurs joueurs ont interrompu
prématurément leur carrière en équipe de
france on a l'impression que les joueurs
n'ont plus envie de jouer en équipe de
france qui n'en rapporte pas grand chose
financièrement peux vous dire que vous
vous trompez dans votre impression est
que les joueurs n'ont qu'un souci c'est
d'avoir nationaux je rappellerai
simplement que si eric cantona à faire
des transferts les plus importants de
l'année
c'est parce qu'il a brillé en équipe de
france et qu'il a brillé en sélection
nationale avec les espoirs et les
joueurs sont tout à fait conscients de
l'importance
une sélection en équipe de france pour
le futur de leur carrière
fournet fayard suis pas spécialiste mais
me permettez moi devant les
téléspectateurs de me faire un peu
l'avocat du diable qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ceux qui disent que cantona
et ma foi je dis tout haut ce que
certains pensent tout bas puis quelques
temps que tout le monde a le droit de
s'exprimer dans ce pays mais à mon avis
un international n'a pas le droit de le
faire il est soumis et une attitude de
réserve qui me paraît importante une
équipe encore plus quand on est dans
certaines difficultés comme celle que
nous traversons actuellement au niveau
du groupe équipe de france eh bien on
doit être solidaire non seulement sur le
terrain mais dans la vie en général
et c'est un grand sujet d'inquiétude à
part la faute qui a été commise et que
nous aurons bientôt à juger il y a aussi
le futur
le grand problème pourrait se poser
henri michel actuellement c'est de dire
ce que eric cantona est un garçon qui
sera fiable pour le futur est-ce que la
situation que nous avons connue ce soir
malgré les dispositions qui fait état
aujourd'hui est ce que cela ne se
reproduira pas à la veille d'un match
capital par exemple vous voyez un petit
peu les conséquences dernières questions
internationales
l'international est quelqu'un qui doit
être fière de porter son maillot se
battre pour le défendre et qui doit
encore une fois être professionnel
d'intérêt général jusqu'au bout merci
dernières questions concrètes
oui président en rugby on est très dur
avec les joueurs qui s'écarte du droit
chemin est ce qu'on peut envisager que
cantona soit suspendue dans le
championnat pour jouer avec marseille en
croire monsieur le président la
fédération a tout pouvoir décisionnel
dans ce domaine là
discipline lui appartient en propre mais
le rugby et le rugby et le football et
le football
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct de lyon et bonsoir au revoir leur
voile c'est parti depuis hier soir pour
la deuxième transat québec saint malo
aux dernières nouvelles c'est le favori
jet services barré par serge madec qui
est en tête le point avec claude et marc
il y avait très peu de vent alors ils
ont dit c'est toute leur voile ils ce
sont les équipiers de serge madec
skipper de jet services
le grand favori de cette transat
québec-saint-malo la course a démarré
hier à 19h30 heure française dans la
baie du saint laurent à québec
c'est pierre follenfant et son charente
maritime qui ont pris le meilleur départ
avant de laisser la place logiquement à
jet services actuellement le vent est de
7 à 8 noeuds et les positions sont les
suivantes premier jet services avec 50
milles environ 90 km d'avancé sur un
groupe comprenant elf aquitaine de jean
morel fujicolor de mike birch sap turbo
de françois boucher groupe pierre 1er de
florence arthaud et laiteries
mont-saint-michel d'olivier moussy le
premier monocoque et en écureuil
d'aquitaine de titouan lamazou durée
prévue de cette traversée
environ 12 jours
quasiment plus tôt là vraiment la fin du
suspense à londres tous les spécialistes
sont trompés la princesse d'york mais
vous le savez il ya quelques jours ne se
prénommera pas victoria ni charlotte ni
annabelle finalement c'est béatrice qui
a rallié les suffrages
béatrice un prénom qui rend hommage à la
famille royale d'espagne c'est le
spécialiste du who's who de
l'aristocratie britannique qu'il affirme
à londres le commentaire attendri de
philippe harrouard elle s'appelle donc
béatrice elisabeth marie et porte le
titre de saône altesse royale la
princesse beatrice d'york le mystère est
levé
la 5ème petite-fille de la reine un nom
peu usité dans la famille royale la
dernière princesse à s'appeler des
actrices fut une fille de la reine
victoria
c'était il ya cent ans et son arrière
arrière petit fils et l'actuel roi
d'espagne
les anglais doivent être surpris si l'on
en croit le bookmaker william hill pas
un parieur ne s'est prononcé pour
béatrice qui était offert à 100 contre 1
pour ceux qui ont des lettres béatrice
est aussi le nom de l'héroïne d'une
pièce de shakespeare qui s'appelle
beaucoup de bruit pour rien et ce n'est
pas un jeune me voilà après le journal
n'oubliez pas la météo avec laurent
cabrol aux alentours de minuit dernier
journal avec aubry et de l'air dom à
6h45 télématin 7h45 les quatre vérités
gérard morin recevra alexandre d'oslo ii
smolar spécialiste de la pologne au cnrs
13h hervé claude pour l'édition de la mi
journée
je vous retrouve demain 20h merci de
votre fidélité et bonsoir